Sometimes there's a glitch in the matrix
where the limitations of the old
operating system and laid bare and
something new pokes through.
There's been dozens of responses to the
Jordan Peterson Channel Four interview
already.
What makes this one different?
Well,
I have a pretty unique perspective.
In October last year I went to Toronto
to interview Jordan Peterson,
this home from where I came in from
London last night.
I turned the interview into the first
full length documentary about Jordan
Peterson's ideas.
I was pretty sure he'd soon become a lot
more famous and be recognized as one of
the most significant public thinkers,
but I couldn't possibly have predicted
how he breakthrough to a mass audience.
A few weeks later Peter's and did an
interview with journalists,
Kathy Newman on channel four news in the
UK,
a program I worked on as reporter and
producer for 10 years.
It was a sensation.
Millions watched it online,
tens of thousands commented and
overwhelming majority felt.
Peterson had been unfairly represented
and in the week since it hasn't stopped,
Peterson has been asked about it
constantly on the most high profile
online shows 12 rules for life.
So without reading this.
So what you're saying is sort of like
there's only 12 things you need to know
in like,
right?
That's it.
Yeah.
Well yeah.
This,
um,
this interview that you just did with
this woman kathy new mission was that in
the UK it was channel four UK.
So what does this glitch say about the
state of mainstream media and the
culture at large?
My diagnosis of what's actually
happening is that people are moving
further and further away from what is
what thinking actually is at more and
more into merely running a script.
And what does Jordan Peterson actually
think?
It's so controversial.
You are misrepresented more than anyone
I know,
you know,
weird way.
You are villainized in a weird way where
um,
I can't believe that these people are
honestly looking at your opinions and
coming up with these conclusions.
I believe this encounter struck such a
nerve because it's a cultural watershed
moment scene properly as Peterson would
say.
It's archetypal in that it contains
layers and layers of meaning
that go right to the heart of the
biggest rift we're seeing play out in
the culture over the next 50 minutes.
I'm going to do my best to unpack it
from the clash between new and old
media.
There's also why Youtube is going to
kill tv because
television,
by its nature,
all of these narrow broadcast
technologies,
they re they rely on forcing the story
all the way down to the mythological an
archetype or level.
I thought of videology says fragmentary
mythologies.
That's where they get their archetype
will in psychological power in the
postmodern world.
And this seems to be something that's
increasingly seeping out into the
culture at large.
You have nothing but the tyrannical
father.
Nothing but the destructive force of
masculine consciousness and nothing but
the benevolent,
benevolent great mother.
And it's uh,
it's an appalling ideology and it seems
to me that it's sucking the vitality,
which is exactly what you'd expect.
Symbolically.
It's sucking the vitality of our culture
until off.
How do we move forward constructively
rather than just adding to the
polarization.
I've been a journalist for 16 years in
the newsroom of the BBC and channel four
and then making documentaries.
I moved away from the front line of news
sometime ago and started learning
psychology,
which is what first drew me to Jordan
Peterson from a distance.
I've started to see the blind spots of
the establishment media much more
clearly.
I spent some of the best years of my
working life at channel four news and
have a huge amount of respect and
gratitude to the program.
But I'm making this film because I feel
so strongly that if we can't have open
conversations about the kind of topics
Peterson is raising,
we're in serious trouble.
My book went up to number two and on
amazon.com in the u s the next day,
right?
It's number one in Canada.
It's number three in the UK.
All on Amazon.
I couldn't have asked for more
publicity.
Right?
And so I could also be sitting back and
saying,
well,
you know,
she tried to my a person who regarded
herself as my ideological opponent tried
to go after my philosophy and my
reputation on national TV failed
brutally and has been taken apart for
it.
It's like this is a good day,
but I don't regard it as a good day.
I don't think it's a good day.
I think that it's evidence of the
instability of the times that we're in.
It would have been much better for me
and for everyone else if what we would
have had was a real conversation.
You said that it's actually a sign of
the times where things could go really
wrong for all of us really soon.
Yeah,
we're,
we're playing with fire and what do you
mean by this?
Can you,
can you elaborate?
Well,
things go wrong and cultures all the
time,
right?
You get,
you get the polarization increases until
people start to act it out.
Peterson is one of the new breed of
thinkers made famous almost completely
by the Internet,
not the broadcast media arts of a
powerful new informal network being
called the intellectual dark web and the
mainstream media is based on an old
model that
is being replaced by new media and new
technology so quickly that it's false or
becoming glaringly obvious.
Fortunately,
thanks to Youtube podcasting and however
else you get shows like this one,
the mainstream media stranglehold on
information,
which really is a stranglehold on your
ability to think clearly about the
issues of the day is crumbling at an
incredible rate.
Now the question is who and what will
replace it?
A few months ago,
one of my favorite people to sit across
this table from Eric Weinstein came up
with the phrase intellectual dark web to
describe this eclectic mix of people
from Sam Harris to Ben Shapiro,
to his brother,
Bret Weinstein to Jordan Peterson,
all of whom are figuring out ways to
have the important and often dangerous
conversations that are completely
ignored by the mainstream.
It's why I would argue that this
collection of people are actually more
influential at this point than whatever
collection of cable news pundits you can
come up with.
If you think I'm being hyperbolic about
the growing influence of this group,
just check the traction that these
people get on twitter or facebook
compared to our mainstream competitors.
Twitter may not be real life as I say in
my twitter bio,
but it is some barometer of what the
Zeitgeists is right now.
What unites this group of thinkers is a
sense that the set of ideas that have
run western culture for years are
breaking down and that the chaos of the
moment is the attempt to find new ones.
It's nearly all happening online.
Part of the problem that we have right
now in our culture is trying to diagnose
the level at which the discussion should
be taking place and I think the reason
that this is a tumultuous time is
because it actually is a time for
discussion of first principles and it's,
it's that first principles are virtually
at the level of theology,
right?
Because first principles are the things
that you assume and then move forward.
It's like,
well,
what should we assume while the dignity
of the human soul?
But start with that.
You can't treat yourself properly
without assuming that you can't have a
relationship with another person.
You can't stabilize your family.
You can't have a functional society.
So what does it mean for this human soul
to have dignity?
Well,
the part of the idea is that you're
participating in creation itself,
and you do that with your actions in
your language,
and you get to decide whether you're
tilting the world a bit more towards
heaven or a bit more towards hell.
And that's actually what you're doing.
So that's a place where the literal in
the metaphorical truth come together.
And people are very,
they're terrified of that idea as they
should be because it's a massive
responsibility.
They also argue that the central problem
is polarization boosted by social media.
Peterson's work looks at how people are
hardwired to see the world differently.
A lot of what determines your political
orientation is biological temperament,
far more than people realize.
So for example,
left leaning people liberals let's say,
although that's kind of Miss Misnomer,
but we'll keep with the terminology.
Liberals are high in a trait called
openness,
which is one of the big five personality
traits and it's associated with interest
in abstraction and interest in
aesthetics.
It's the best predictor of liberal
political leaning and they're low in
trait conscientiousness,
which is due to fullness and and
orderliness in particular.
Whereas the conservatives are the
opposite.
They're high in conscientiousness,
their due to in orderly and they're low
in openness and that makes them really
good managers and administrators,
administrators and often businessmen,
but not very good entrepreneurs because
the entrepreneurs are almost all drawn
from the liberal types.
And so these are really fundamental
fundamentally biologically predicated
differences.
And there you might think about them as
different sets of,
of opportunities and limitations and and
certainly different ways of screening
the world and each of those different
temperamental types needs.
The other type,
let's call this a diversity issue.
If you start understanding that the
person that you're talking to who
doesn't share your political views isn't
stupid,
that's the first thing necessarily.
They might be,
but so might you be,
no.
Stupidity isn't.
The differences in intelligence are not
the prime determinant of differences in
political belief.
All right,
so you might be talking to someone who's
more conscientious and less creative
than you if you're,
if you happen to be a liberal,
but that doesn't mean that that person's
perspective is not valid and it doesn't
mean that they wouldn't outperform you
in some domains because they would.
So one thing to remember is people
actually do see the world differently.
It's not merely that they,
that they're possessively of of ill,
he informed opinions.
The whole point of the deal of a
democracy is to continue the dialogue
between people of different
temperamental types so that we don't
move so far to the right that everything
becomes encapsulated and stone and
doesn't move or so far to the left that
everything dissolves in a kind of a
mealy mouth chaos.
And the only way that you can,
you can navigate between those two
scholls is by is through discussion,
which is why free speech is such an
important value.
It's the thing that keeps the
temperamental types from being at each
other's throats.
In the aftermath of the trump election,
that came as such a shock to most of the
media.
One of the most widely shared analysis
pieces was from deep code.
It describes how the establishment
mainstream media perspective based
around liberal values of openness and
inclusivity he calls the blue church is
being challenged by a new web based
insurgency,
a red religion based on the values of
tribalism.
The Culture Wars of the 20th century was
a decisive success for blue and a
effectively a route for
red.
So what we see first is that red was
forced to move into a deeply exploratory
phase.
Second that it did this in a context
where as it turns out,
things were changing meaningfully,
quite significantly.
In fact,
it from my perspective,
they in a world historical level,
the emergence of entirely new forms of
communication and therefore entirely new
forms of sense making and coherence.
He concludes that the blue church is in
the process of collapse as its dominant
ideology can't adapt to changing
reality,
but that a combination of the two sets
of values of blue and red is essential.
We are conscious,
yeah,
and effective in the world in groups not
as individuals.
And the ingredients of those groups
include aspects that are currently
showing up as both red and blue.
Um,
I propose somewhat strongly that uh,
either red nor blue is pure elements
contain the ingredients necessary to
actually be adaptive to reality.
Um,
this is a disaster.
In fact,
um,
it's a little bit like mmm.
Separating the hand in the eye.
You know,
you're the,
I can see if the eye takes itself as
being,
the essence of virtue is separates
itself from the ability to do the same
thing with the hand.
For most of human history,
these groups have actually always
commingled there necessary that they
actually relate to each other in a
deeply healthy,
uh,
and direct fashion.
Uh,
their separation into armed camps is
extinction are actually,
do you live the values of red that you
think blue needs to integrate or some
way or to reintegrate?
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
That's actually pretty easy
responsibility.
I mean we've,
we've actually even seen it,
um,
the ability to,
make a commitment and keep it,
um,
which,
which by the way ideologically shows up.
Is that a duty or loyalty?
But those are both ideologies.
The,
the,
the deeper sense is that ability,
um,
responsibility both at the individual
and the group level,
the ability to actually really make a
personal sacrifice on the part of the
group.
That's actually a deeply red value.
Um,
and I don't mean that by the way as
politically ideological,
uh,
certainly there are people who,
um,
are currently part of blue who feel that
deeply.
What I'm saying is that,
that that shows up much,
much more intensely in red.
And when you're feeling it in blue,
you're actually feeling a red value and
that's good.
Mixing them is crucial.
Um,
cause that's very Jordan Peterson asks
to w how would you,
how would you define Jordan Peterson or
do you think the fact that the issue is
that he is,
is not within one of those
two camps?
I think that's the point.
I think that he grasps directly the fact
that human beings can only actually make
sense of the world by virtue of
communication with other human beings.
And this is all about the notion of ad
mixture had that one must have a mixture
of,
of what I mean he uses the mythic poetic
to make sense that the order order and
chaos,
uh,
the way or the Taoist way is the al
chemical admixture of order and chaos.
And that's it.
Like that's how you do it.
And so if you bias towards orderliness,
uh,
you find yourself in a rigid
non-adaptive,
uh,
noncreative not exploratory framework,
um,
which will die because the world changes
if you buy us towards chaos,
um,
you,
you eat your young and evaporate.
Um,
which also ties for obvious reasons,
uh,
and the key is to actually be enabled
these things to be in relationship with
each other.
And vital healthy relationship with each
other and I think that's the,
in some sense,
the essence of what he's focusing on and
in sort of the core of what he's asking
about it
in his heart for the broadcast media to
get a handle on because the depth of his
thought means he doesn't fit easily into
any of their categories.
The clash with Kathy Newman was his
breakthrough moment where the new world
met the old,
to give the context from Kathy Newman
side,
she has to do dozens of interviews each
month.
Peterson is hard to get a grip on and he
sure as hell looks controversial.
She's also focused on getting soundbites
for a five minute cut down of the
interview for TV.
Not a long conversation for online.
The interview was ridiculous.
It was a ridiculous interview.
I mean,
I listened to it or watched it several
times.
I was like,
this is so strange.
It's like her determination to turn it
into a conflict too.
It's one of the issues that I have with
television shows.
Yeah.
Because they have a very limited amount
of time and they're trying to make
things as salacious as possible.
They want to have these soundbites,
these clickbait soundbites,
and she just went into it incredibly
confrontational.
Not Trying to find your actual
perspective,
but trying to force you to defend a non
nonrealistic.
Yeah.
Perspective.
Yes.
While I was at,
I was the hypothetical villain of her
imagination essentially.
No.
This is also why Youtube is going to
kill tv because television,
by its nature,
all of these narrow broadcast
technologies,
they re they rely on forcing the story.
Right,
because it has to happen now.
It has to happen like often in five
minutes because they only broadcast five
minutes of that interview.
They did put the whole thing up on
youtube.
To their credit.
Yeah,
it,
it hasn't ceased to amaze me yet.
I think that they thought that the
interview went fine
after the interview.
Channel Four news found themselves at
the center of an online storm,
which included some nasty,
a misogynistic
attacks.
It's understandable that they just
wanted it to go away,
but online is forever and as the center
of gravity continues to shift away from
traditional media,
this interview is,
I would argue,
a slow motion and continuing car crash
for Channel Four's credibility.
So why did it happen?
Partly the limitations of the medium of
TV,
but also because of the institutional
political blindness of the mainstream
media.
I've always considered myself of the
liberal left,
but especially since the election of
trump,
I've been trying to understand what
happened and I'm convinced that the
polarization we're seeing is mainly
driven by the shadow side of liberalism
in particular,
where supposedly inclusive social
justice liberalism stops being inclusive
and secretly judges and despises people
that don't think the same way.
The rebellion of trump and brexit was a
direct response.
Yeah.
As Eerie Harris argues in this article
in Colette,
the new gatekeepers of the media have
become a new bourgeoisie in forcing a
rigid etiquette and using the rights of
the oppressed as an excuse to put
forward a vision of the kind of society
they personally want to live in.
On the surface level,
it's about how a narrow social justice
worldview embodied by Kathy Newman in
the interview became the new status quo
and how this institutional bias of much
of the mainstream media means it can't
see or understand the forces that are
challenging this new consensus.
The counterculture used to be on the
left,
but once it one the culture war,
it left space for a new counter culture,
the biggest manifestation is the red
pill phenomena,
which the mainstream media mistakenly
assumes is the same thing as the alt
right.
I was surprised to discover the overlap
between,
um,
what I'm into a particularly like,
Greek philosophy and stoicism and the
old right.
Who I'd always thought of,
you know,
if I come across from the tour,
I thought that was kind of,
um,
squibb allied boogie man,
you know,
uh,
completely unpalatable like extremists,
in their,
in their basements.
And then to discover that,
um,
you know,
a lot of them were a lot of people in
stoicism and also really into the old
right.
Made me wonder what was going on and why
people like me.
We're getting radicalized,
kind of drawn into it.
You're explaining what stoicism is for
is basically an ancient Greek
philosophy,
which,
um,
with became very popular in the Roman,
uh,
you know,
we did the emperor marcus or radius was
a stoic for example.
And it's in some ways like a Western
form of Buddhism.
It's like a therapy for the emotions.
It teaches you to take responsibility
for your thoughts,
to take a nearby,
to take some control of your emotions.
So in some ways it's putting forward a
model of a strength and integrity and
kind of resilience.
Uh,
I made adversity and rapid change.
So for that reason it's become very
popular in the last 10 years.
I think this is also why from my
perspective,
at least someone like Jordan Peterson is
often looked from the outside as being
aligned with the alt right because he
has a similar message.
But it's,
there are crucial differences I think,
between what we would consider.
I mean,
certainly white nationalism would be an
essential part of the outright,
I would say,
of any useful definition.
And that's certainly not characteristic
of,
of Jordan Peterson from my experience,
there's a crucial difference at least
between stoicism and your right.
Uh,
even though a lot of old writers into
stoicism ending that stoicism and maybe
Jordan Peterson as well.
I don't,
I'm not an expert on him.
Talk about the way to gain strength and
maturity and power is internal.
It's to take responsibility for your own
thoughts and feelings.
Whilst I think people,
sometimes men white look for that sense
of power and control externally by
suppressing or,
or,
or segregating anyone who they feel
threatened by,
whether that's other colors or other
sexualities or,
or,
or gender.
So there's a crucial difference there.
One is about kind of inner integrity,
uh,
and,
and it just kind of,
um,
being strong within yourself.
And the other is about trying to take
control through the kind of exterior
borders and fences,
if you see what I mean.
Every public appearance that I've made
that's related to the sort of topics
that we're discussing is overwhelmingly,
man,
it's like,
it's like 85 to 90%.
And so I thought,
wow,
that's weird.
Like what the hell's going on here.
Exactly.
And then the other thing I've noticed is
that I've been talking a lot to the
crowds that I'd be talking to,
not about rights,
but about responsibility,
right?
Because he can't have the bloody
converse.
What are you doing?
You can't have the conversation about
rights without the conversation about
responsibility because your rights are
my responsibility.
That's what they are technically.
So you just can't have only half of that
discussion and we're only having half
that discussion.
And the question is,
well,
what the hell are you leaving out if you
only have that half of the discussion?
And the answer is what?
You're leaving out responsibility.
And then the question is,
well what are you leaving out?
If you're leaving out responsibility?
And the answer might be,
well maybe you're leaving out the
meaning of life.
That's what looks like to me.
It's like here you are suffering away.
What makes it worthwhile,
right?
You know you're completely,
oh,
you're completely,
you have no idea what you're you.
It's almost impossible to describe how
bad an idea that is.
Responsibility.
That's what gives life meaning.
It's like lift a load,
then you can tolerate yourself.
Right?
Cause look at your useless,
easily hurt,
easily killed.
Why should you have any self respect?
That's the story of the fall.
Pick something up and carry it.
Pick,
make it heavy enough so that you can
think,
yeah,
well useless as I am.
At least I could move that from there to
there.
Well what's really cool about that is
that when I talked to these crowds about
this,
the man's eyes light up and that's very
like I've seen that phenomena because
I've been talking about this
mythological material for a long time
and I can see when I'm watching crowds,
people,
you know their eyebrows lift,
their eyes light up because I've put
something together for them,
not sweat,
mythological stories do.
So I'm not taking responsibility for
that.
That's what the story is due.
So I say this story,
when people go click,
click,
you know when their eyes light up.
But this responsibility thing,
that's a whole new order of this is that
young men are so hungry for that.
It is unbelievable.
It just blows me away.
It's like,
really?
That's what's,
that's the counterculture.
Grow the hell up and do something
useful.
Really.
I could do that.
Oh,
I'm so excited by that idea.
No one ever mentioned that before.
It's like rights,
rights,
Jesus.
It's,
it's,
it's appalling.
It's,
it's,
and,
and I feel that that's deeply felt by
the people who are,
who are coming out to,
to listen to these sorts of things,
to there.
They've had enough of that.
So,
and they better have because it's a
nonproductive motive being
responsibility.
Man.
Peterson is part of the counterculture
that he describes himself as a classic
liberal and yet he's frequently
described as right wing by the media.
This is not limited to Peterson.
James Damore is infamous.
Google memo was described everywhere.
There's an anti diversity screed despite
him specifically stating he wanted to
encourage more diversity in the
workplace.
Many believe that the channel four
interview,
it was a significant moment and exposing
this mindset as dogmatic,
reactionary and fixed.
So during the interview we see an
example of a,
um,
uh,
a delusional framework that is what
appears to be largely incapable of
perceiving,
reacting to reality in real time.
But much more interesting is what
happened afterwards,
which was the sort of the self healing
and policing mechanism of the larger
social consensus of how,
when,
how the Blue Church
reactively goes about maintaining the
integrity of its frame.
Um,
and so what ended up happening was there
was a break in the frame,
there was a glitch in the matrix.
The,
uh,
mechanisms of the Blue Church reacted to
endeavor,
to control the frame and to convert it
into a way of sense of,
of,
uh,
making sense of the,
what occurred that still maintained the
integrity of its frame.
And you can do,
you mean when they tried to characterize
it as a sort of abusive trolls and
you'll write hero and all of that is
actually exactly the sort of a,
to use a military language.
It was a fall back position that was a
reactive,
almost instinctual and not all,
most in fact precisely.
Instinction was that pure habit.
Uh,
there was no,
uh,
thoughtfulness or even,
um,
strategic action.
There it was.
If if x,
then y and in this case why is here's a
set of things that one does to
reestablish the dominant frame and now
we're now we're two levels deep.
You know,
the first level was a sort of self
evident disaster,
but then the second level was also a
relatively self avid disaster and there
isn't really a third level,
um,
in this approach.
So it ends up happening and this is
again,
we can kind of just think about this
from ordinary psychology.
Um,
this is how delusions fall apart because
try as we might,
our desire to interpret reality to me,
but we want it to mean at the end of the
day will always be checked against what
reality actually is.
Maybe some time,
you know,
we're pretty good at,
at,
at making things up in pretending,
but eventually reality is reality.
This isn't to say that Peterson is not
controversial.
He's saying things that challenge the
most deeply held assumptions of the new
establishment narrative.
I guess the other reason that people are
on my case to some degree is because I
have made a strong case,
which I think is fully documented by the
scientific literature,
that there are intrinsic differences say
between men and women.
And I think the evidence on that,
this is the thing that staggered me,
is that no serious scientists have
debated that for like four decades.
It's that argument was done by the time
I went to graduate school.
Everyone knew that human beings,
we're not a blank slate.
That biological forces parameterize the
way that we thought and felt and acted
in and,
and valued.
Everyone knew that the fact that this
has become somehow debatable again is
just,
especially because it's being done by
legislative Fiat,
they're forcing it
pause.
Peterson's argument based on years of
psychological research is that much of
the political conflicts,
uh,
due to try to integrate the different
political temperaments of men and women.
We were talking about the relatively,
the relative evolutionary roles of men
and women.
And this is speculative obviously.
And,
and because our research did indicate
it's tentative research so far that that
the,
the SGS sjw sort of equality above all
else philosophy is more prevalent among
women.
It's predicted by the personality
factors that are more common among
women.
So agreeableness and high negative
emotion,
primarily agreeableness.
But in addition it's also predicted by
being female.
And so I've been thinking about that a
lot because,
well men are bailing out of the
humanities like mad and pretty much out
of the universities except for stem,
the women are moving in like mad and
they're also moving into the political
sphere like mad.
And this is new,
right?
We've never had this happen before and
we do.
No,
no,
do not know what the significance of it
is.
It's only 50 years old.
And so we were thinking about this and
so I don't know what you think about
this proposition,
but imagine that,
that,
that historically speaking,
it's something like women were
responsible for distribution and men
were responsible for production.
Something like that.
And maybe,
and maybe that's only the case really in
the tight confines of the immediate
family,
but that doesn't matter because that's
most of the evolutionary landscape for
human beings anyways.
What the women does it did was make sure
that everybody got enough.
Okay.
And that seems to me to be one of the
things that's driving,
at least in part the sjw demand for,
for equity and equality.
It's like,
let's make sure everybody has enough.
well look,
fair enough.
You know,
I mean you,
you can't,
you can't argue with that.
But there's,
there's an antipathy between that and
the reality of differential
productivity.
You know,
because people really do differ in their
productivity.
I think that the sjw phenomena is
different and I think it is associated
at least in part with the rise of women
to political power and,
and we don't know what women are like
when they have political power because
they've never had it.
I mean there's been queens obviously and
that sort of thing.
Just being female authority figures and
females have wielded far more power
historically than feminists generally
like to admit.
But this is a different thing and we
don't know what,
what I've truly female political
philosophy would be like,
but it might be,
especially if it's not being well
examined and it isn't very sophisticated
conceptually,
it could easily be,
well,
let's makes sure things are distributed
equally well.
Yeah,
but sorry,
fly.
One of the Peterson's main influences is
the psychologist Carl Young human
psychology was built around the concept
of the shadow,
all the things about ourselves.
We don't want to accept our anger,
negativity,
unconscious judgments,
and how we need to integrate all those
disowned parts to grow.
I'm convinced that's what's happening on
a vast cultural level since leaving
channel four news.
I've retrained as a counselor and
started leading personal growth
workshops for men on thought a lot about
how these unconscious gender dynamics
are playing out in the culture.
One of the central concepts is Yum's
idea of animus anima possession,
or we each have both an inner masculine
and feminine essence in a man.
When he's unconsciously possessed by his
feminine side,
his Anima,
he becomes withdrawn,
moody and reactive.
And when a woman is possessed by her
male side,
the animus,
she becomes aggressive and dominating.
And how many women are pushed into that
by the nature of the modern workplace.
The Kathy Newman I know is warm,
compassionate,
uh,
successful and talented journalist.
None of this is criticism of her,
just the role she was playing in the
interview.
I would say technically,
and this is might be interesting for
people who were interested in union
psychology.
If you want to understand what Carl Jung
meant by animus possession,
which is a very difficult concept then
that that interview was a textbook case
of having a discussion with someone who
is animus,
possessed life has been moving forward
for three and a half billion years and
it moves forward in these pattern
matters,
like the dominance hierarchy for
example.
So that's that.
Let's call that the masculine archetype.
It's part of the masculine archetype.
In fact,
youngest proclamation was that the
female representation of the mail.
So that's the animus is the dominance
hierarchy.
It's the patriarchy.
So that's the,
that's the unconscious archetype,
which I think is extremely interesting
given what's happened,
say in the women's movement because
that's what's projected onto men and,
and it can be projected in a very
negative way.
It doesn't have to be,
but it can be.
And so an animus possessed woman treat a
man as if he's the manifestation of the
tyrannical patriarchy.
He's a group.
He's that group of men.
Yeah,
the group of bad band.
Now actually you watch the Jordan
Peterson Kathy Newman interview.
What did he,
what did he think?
Thank
who I,
my whole body contracted and I,
I felt so sad for womanhood.
I felt disappointed and um,
I could see how the shadow part of
womanhood was acting out.
I could see how the collective rage was
acting through Kathy Newman.
And this is what happens is that when
that's unknown and it's projected
blindly on to whatever stick,
whatever it sticks.
And it was very clear that she already
had an agenda and she already had a
projection that she was just looking to
stay.
She was,
she was just looking to have that
confirmed.
So I felt on behalf of women,
I felt sad and disappointed because we
to have intelligent conversations.
And I also want to say that this isn't,
even though the,
the specific example is the Kathy Newman
Jordan an interview.
It's not specific to,
to Kathy Newman.
I think the fact that that interview has
resonated with so many people that has
been so popular shows that actually
something archetype was going on in
that,
in that interaction.
And I think as well,
why it's gone viral is a lot of people
watching it recognize those dynamics.
They're like,
I've been in conversations like that.
Yeah.
I've been in this conversation when
nothing I say works when nothing I say
he gets through.
Yeah.
Um,
so there's something sort of fundamental
about about the masculine and feminine
dynamic that is going on in there.
What do you think that is?
I think Jordan Peterson,
he's every man.
Kathy Newman,
she's every woman.
I can tap into that rage like this.
I know it in myself and women that say
they don't,
they just denying it because it is in
the collective.
So in that sense it just highlighted
what,
what's there.
It's wonderful because here we really
get to look at why is this so important?
Why is it so important to listen to,
to a thinker like Jordan Peterson and
take it seriously and say,
what can we do with it?
It's just so obvious that it's needed
because if this is where we are,
if this is where society and cultures
is,
if this is the ability to have an
intelligent conversations conversation
than we are in trouble,
I really feel that there is this
collective,
subconscious rage that is just boiling
in women and it's coming up in so many
ways.
We see,
we see in the media and,
and,
and what's going on is this unknown rage
that comes up in,
in many different ways.
Um,
and on one hand it needs to come out.
We need to clear it.
It needs to be expressed.
It needs to be acknowledged.
On the other hand,
it's not enough.
This is only like this is breaking the
ice so that the next step of evolution
can,
you know,
consciousness can start coming through.
And that's what I'm lacking in women.
It's really to take responsibility for
what we do as women in our manipulation,
in our seduction,
in our control.
And,
and it's so easy for women to say,
but that's just because we're angry and
mandate this and patriarchy,
but it's,
um,
it's such a lack of responsibility and
this women really need to know.
I mean that's the kind of shadow work is
the acceptance that we all have shadows
that men certainly have a shadow.
There was a shadow around masculinity,
but there's also a shadow around
femininity.
And while part of the cultural now is
toxic masculinity and everyone knows
what you mean by toxic toxic
masculinity.
If you talk about toxic femininity,
everyone still knows what you mean,
but you can't have that conversation.
Yeah.
Which is,
it's,
it's interesting what is allowed to be
said and what is not allowed to be said
at the moment.
And that,
that I think is,
is very dangerous that certain topics,
certain conversations or off or off
limits.
Yeah.
And this is where we see where,
where we see the victim,
persecutor dynamics activates it because
women become the become the victims and
we make ourselves the victims and we
persecute men.
But in that aggression,
in that rage,
and when we are the victims,
we are in perfect control.
We become the persecutors because we say
it's all about blame.
Did this and men need to take
responsibility.
But in that we've become the
persecutors.
Yeah.
And it's also very difficult as well
because one imagines that that combative
attitude is something that has served
her well in the past.
And it's something that she's maybe felt
forced into because of the nature of the
society that he's operating it.
So it's a kind of catch 22 situation for
the many successful women because they
feel that they're pushed to be more
masculine.
Yeah.
And then when they're more masculine,
they get judged for being more
masculine.
It's,
it's very sad.
And,
and,
and I can see that dynamics being played
out.
Absolutely.
But I think the only thing we can do is
to take responsibility and say,
okay,
I'm doing that.
Do I really want to compromise my
femininity?
Do I want to compromise my integrity?
Do I want to compromise my gender and
play that or is there another way that I
can be powerful without being
aggressive,
without playing a power game,
but resting in my natural power,
resting in my natural dignity,
resting in that deep rootedness that we
both have in our agendas that when we
are at peace with it and when we
acknowledge it in ourselves,
it's that as a natural thing,
and this is the thing,
I don't want to make this personal about
Katherine Newman because it's,
it's in that potential is in every
woman,
but it's because we are persecuting our
own femininity.
What's being played out that we are
doing it to ourselves because we don't
trust that it's good enough to be a
woman.
We don't trust that we can have
conversations that come from the felt
embodied perspective.
We don't trust that we're connected to
truth because these,
these masculine ways have been,
have been very strong and women have
been denying their own power.
In my work over many years of working
with this,
I find that very few women grew up in
households which really loved,
admired,
respected on or heard,
cherished the feminine.
And so there is for so many of the women
who've grown up in the,
I dunno,
the last hundred years that say,
um,
uh,
kind of devaluation of the feminine that
gets taken on and of course,
and as well as abuse,
aggression,
all sorts of things.
So very many women out of an intelligent
strategy to survive,
develop their masculine side as a
defense against that devaluation for the
feminine.
And over time they become very
identified with that mask on side.
The male equivalent is anima possession
in Anima possession.
It's the loss of relaxed confidence in
the groundedness in the masculine and is
overwhelmed by his own inner feminine
side.
And it creates a passive withdrawn,
moody,
Bitchy,
complaining,
not showing up kind of guy,
which I think is really so much what
feminists are angry about.
The don't see them as really angry about
the masculine per se,
but the way that males behave.
And you know,
I have quite a lot of compassion for
that because for myself and most men
that I know,
we weren't really shown how to be as
men.
We didn't really get initiated into it.
And so,
and then the strong thing comes from
feminism and we feel like it's,
it's maleness that's wrong.
It's not,
it's not maleness that's wrong.
And I don't even think feminists,
feminists hate the masculine.
It's like what the call is really for
men is to develop their masculine
strength,
presence,
courage,
be relaxed and confident,
be protective and be strong.
And under this kind of assault,
which has come from a lot of animals,
possessed women,
a lot of men have retreated.
And I think gone into feeling guilty
about being men and have become passive
indecisive.
Um,
and in that way a kind of feminized man
has emerged.
Yeah.
Lacy's follow eight pieces and store
recognize his analysis goes all the way
down to the bedrock,
to the archetypal structures of
consciousness itself.
The thing that I really see happening,
and you can tell me what you think about
this in Norman's book consciousness,
which is masculine,
symbolically masculine for a variety of
reasons,
is,
is viewed as rising up against the
countervailing force of tragedy from an
underlying co feminine,
Symbolically Feminine unconsciousness,
right?
And it's something that can always be
pulled back into that unconsciousness.
That would be the microcosm of that
would be the Friday and eatable mother
familial dynamic where the mother was so
over protective and all encompassing
that she interferes with the development
of the competence,
not only of her sons,
but over daughters of her children in
general.
And it seems to me that that's the
dynamic that's being played out in our
society right now is that there's this
and it's,
it's related in some way that I don't
understand to this,
to this insistence that all forms of
masculine and authority or nothing by
tyrannical power.
So the symbolic representation is
tyrannical father with no appreciation
for the benevolent father and benevolent
mother with no appreciation whatsoever
for the tyrannical mother.
Right.
And that's that cause I thought of
videology is as fragmentary mythologies.
That's where they get their archetype in
psychological power,
right?
And so in a balanced representation,
you have the terrible mother and the
great mother as as noise and laid out so
nicely and you have the terrible father
in the great father.
So that's the fact that culture mangles
you have to death well.
It's also promoting you and developing
you.
You have to see that as balanced.
And then you have the heroic and
adversarial individual.
But in the postmodern world,
and this seems to be something that's
increasingly seeping out into the
culture at large,
you have nothing but the tyrannical
father.
Nothing but the destructive force of
masculine consciousness and nothing but
the benevolent,
benevolent,
great mother.
And it's a,
it's an appalling ideology.
And it seems to me that it's sucking the
vitality,
which,
which is exactly what you would expect
symbolically.
It's sucking the vitality of our
culture.
You see that with the increasing
demolition of,
of young men,
um,
and not only young men in terms of their
academic performance,
which like they're falling way behind in
elementary school way behind in junior
high and bailing out of the universities
like mad.
And so,
and I,
well the public school education has
become completely permeated by this kind
of anti male propaganda.
I mean,
and to me public schools I just a form
of imprisonment,
you know,
right now they are particularly
destructive to young men who have a lot
of physical energy right now.
You know,
I identify as transgender,
Gay Mike Myself,
right?
But I do not,
I do not require the entire world to
alter itself okay.
To,
to fit my particular in the self image.
I do believe in the power of hormones.
I believe that men exist and women exist
and are biologically different.
I think that,
I think there is no cure for,
I'm the cultures ills right now except
if men start standing up away and
demanding that they be respected as men.
Here's the problem.
You know,
this is something my wife has pointed
out to.
She said,
well,
men are going to have to stand up for
themselves.
But here's the problem.
I know how to stand up to a man who's,
who's,
uh,
unfairly trespassed against me.
And the reason I know that is because
the parameters for my resistance are
quite well defined,
which is we talk,
we argue,
we push,
and then it becomes physical,
right?
Like if,
if we move beyond the boundaries of
civil discourse,
we know what the next step is.
Okay.
That's forbidden in,
in discourse with women.
So I don't know,
like it seems to me that it isn't men
that have to stand up and say enough of
this,
even though that is what they should do.
It seems to me that it's same women who
have to stand up against their crazy
sisters and say,
look,
enough of that enough man hating enough
pathology,
enough bringing disgrace on us as a,
as a gender.
But the problem there,
and then I'll start my little tirade,
is that most of the women I know who are
sane are busy doing same things,
right?
They're off.
They have their career,
they have their family,
they're quite occupied and they don't
seem to have the time or maybe even the
interest to go after there.
They're crazy heartbeat sisters.
And so I don't see any regulating force
for that,
that terrible femininity.
And it seems to me to be invading the
culture and undermining the masculine
power of the culture in a way that's,
I think fatal.
I really do believe that.
I too,
I too believe that these are,
this is symptomatic of the decline of
Western culture and,
and we,
and,
and it will just go down flat.
I don't think people realize that,
you know,
masculinity is still exists in the world
as a code among jihadists.
Okay.
And when you have passionate
masculinity,
okay.
Circling the borders,
like the huns in the vandals during the
Roman empire,
that,
that's what I see.
I see this culture rotting from within.
Okay.
And,
and this all link itself,
literally,
we have this bit of combat.
Let's say it produced a scandal.
Now we actually talk about it.
Yeah.
No tricks.
Just to conversation and then everybody
wins.
Right?
Because I can admit whatever mistakes I
made,
she can admit whatever mistakes she
we can drop the persona.
So you're saying the polarization that
we're seeing right now that we are
speaking out,
it's not in the future.
We will x out that polarization if we
don't,
if we keep accelerating and especially
if we keep accelerating it with lies.
Yeah.
You know,
and,
and this,
this whole,
um,
channel four rats,
nest is like 90% lies.
Yeah.
Maybe more.
And I'll,
you know,
a lot of it's ideologically motivated
lies,
but it doesn't matter.
It's still lies.
Like Kathy,
as I said,
there was virtually nothing she said in
that interview that was actually coming
from her,
like,
like a deep part of her soul,
of her persona.
It was all persona.
It was all persona and,
and,
and all use of words in a,
in a expedient manner as tools to
obtain.
I think probably probably status,
dominance,
status and reputation.
Yeah.
I mean what advice would you give to
people too,
to navigate this new world?
The first is a free your mind.
Be Aware of the fact that the habits of
the Blue Church and and how it works,
um,
don't work anymore.
Recognize that your way of making sense
in the world that used to work don't
work and you really,
really need to set yourself free to
begin learning a new child's mind,
beginner's mind.
Um,
second,
um,
this by nature must in fact be
exploratory.
So swim do not make sense prematurely in
spite of the fact that the world feels
dangerous instead of the five that you
may want to protect yourself in this
dangerous world I'm doing.
So to quickly,
uh,
does not allow the natural exploratory
approach to do what it needs to do.
Really just listen and learn.
Go all the way that back down to human
base.
Turn it inward.
Learn how fear shows up in you.
Learn how not to allow fear to drive the
choices that you make.
Learn how to listen to the whole way
that all of you perceives what's going
on.
Become more integrated with your own
body.
Go out into nature,
spend a lot of time not connected to the
chaos that's going on.
And a lot of time reconnecting yourself
with your fundamental capacity to
perceive reality in all the different
modalities that human beings have the
capacity to do.
Then relearn how to use other human
beings as allies and figuring out how to
make sense of the world.
I mean that really relearn like we have
been abused and a constrained by
institutional frameworks that remove us
from our own native capabilities.
So relearn that,
understand how to be a friend and an
ally,
how to have a conversation with somebody
where you're really listening closely to
get a sense of what their perspective
brings to you,
where you're not obligated to agree with
them.
We are not obligated to move out of what
you feel is right to form some new,
uh,
consensus,
reality.
But where you're actually authentically
recognizing that their perspective has
some capacity to bring richness to your
perspective.
Just by the way,
is almost exclusively possible in
person.
And what we're doing right now is an o
cavers and epic need.
We'd be very mindful of the fact that a
linear broadcast is bad and even
interactive bandwidth like this is not
good enough.
You know,
you've got to learn from raw physical
and get yourself into places where your
consensus reality and your habits are
willfully destroyed.
It to human,
to human conversations and,
and get as far with ideology as you can.
Your job is not to know what the fuck is
going on.
Your job has to be absolutely certain
that you have no idea what the fuck is
going on and learn how to feel from raw
chaos,
from raw uncertainty up
then,
and only then are you finally able to
begin the journey of beginning form a
collective intelligence in this new
environment.
That's my advice.
This is why we've created rubber wisdom
to host these conversations,
to try and unpack what's going on and
through our workshops and events start
to build this collective intelligence
for the future.
To see longer versions of the interviews
featured in this film and our full
length documentary about Jordan
Peterson.
Check the rebel wisdom website,
help us create more films about these
subjects by sponsoring us on patreon and
come to our events to have these
conversations in person.